setting out for a long day of gorilla
tracking tourists quickly learned that
nothing here comes easily these animals
you are going to see they are called
Montenegro arenas and the most timeless
efendim top of mountain so on our way we
should expect that shall be going up and
down Maeda the guide isn't kidding they
have a long hike ahead of them the 13
members of the M group were last seen at
the far edge of forest miles away
a few hours into the hike the group
starts up a steep hill slick with mud
and tangled with vines along for the
trek as behavioral ecologist and gorilla
expert Michelle goldsmith she's been
doing research on green Dee's gorillas
for the last five years if they're in a
place with very dense vegetation that
they're eating they won't go very far
sometimes they'll travel 300-400 meters
in a day and then if there's maybe a
preferred site that they want to visit
they'll travel more than a kilometer
there are more than 300 gorillas living
here but there are no guarantees the
group will see any of them today
however in time they find gorillas nests
and fresh gorilla droppings good signs
pushing through the brush the tourists
stop in their tracks
they're being watched a young gorilla
may be a couple years old stands up and
makes himself known
the gorillas move off through the brush
the group follows cautiously and tries
to sidle up next to the family while the
silverback the dominant male rests alone
the group finds a mother with infants
they are entertained by young gorillas
playing in the branches the gorillas
move again
first the silverback then the adult
female with a baby on board followed by
several small ones who it seems have
energy to burn these Apes were
habituated in 1993 and every day for the
last nine years they have been visited
by small groups of tourists it's obvious
they've gotten used to people hanging
around the gorillas watchers have time
to size up these beautiful creatures
mostly they seem concerned with eating
they devour leaves bark fruit and grass
while the adults munch the kid's
roughhouse
finally when the silverback moves off
through the forest yet again it's time
for the group to go their 60 minutes is
up
there are fewer than 700 of these
creatures left on the planet if
effective ways of protecting them aren't
found soon they will vanish from these
forests